I've been very interested in voicemail
because like many people you know when
it first came out I immediately hung up
the phone I didn't want to leave a
message and then of course I became
upset when people didn't have voicemail
so I couldn't leave a message and then
much to my shock and horror I became
upset when the person I had called
answered the phone because I didn't want
to speak to them I just wanted to leave
a message and i thought that voicemail
was a very interesting genre of
communications but as we went forward
and as corporate voicemail took hold and
then as texting and other forms of
communication email etc and mobile
devices materialized it became clear
that that voicemail was deservedly so an
anachronism it was more and more work
less and less efficient for for the
value derived and so I think going
forward one of the most interesting
things that we're going to see is how
people have different technology
communication styles increasingly I
believe you're only going to have
conversations voice conversations with
people who you know and you're going to
use texting and email to set up a
conversation before you have a voicemail
or excluding real-time conversation with
them I think voicemail is an anachronism
I don't think people want to listen to
15 or 20 messages I think they're happy
to scan 15 or 20 texts so I think we're
in a stage where we're basically you're
going to tell a lot about it somebody's
personality whether they want to
communicate with you via email via text
or they want to talk with you on the
phone and the last quasi useful thing I
could say on this is this is really a
demographic phenomenon I don't think
there's anybody I know under the age of
30 who listens to their voicemail you
know and I think most people over the
age of 50 are just too tired to go
through their cues of voicemail
voicemail is a great idea whose time has
come and it's gone so coke pulling the
plug on their voicemail system I don't
think they
I don't think people will care in fact
the irony is for the majority of people
they already have a voicemail system
it's through their mobile phone provider
corporations are going to get out of
that kind of a business and I'll go one
step further I think the era of
corporate email is going to vanish too
because I think people are using
LinkedIn and Facebook Yammer and other
quote unquote enterprise social media
platforms to manage interaction yes I
think everybody will always have an
email address but in terms of time
invested in time spent i think within
the decade email is going to sound and
smell suspiciously like voicemail as a
platform for where were cats not